i i wonder minister whether you might be
able to confirm the reports this morning
that
self-isolation for those who are
symptomatic covered 19 symptomatic
is to be extended from seven to ten days
well this is a decision that's
clinically led the
chief medical officer will be setting
out details
later today what i would say is that i i
can't steal his thunder but what i will
say is that we will always do
what is necessary to protect people and
we we we are guided by the clinical
judgments by the science in this as
it as across the board i i understand
the desire not to not to steal
uh jonathan van tam's thunder but at the
same time it's all over the papers this
morning
someone in government someone in your
department is presumably briefing this
stuff
i'm just wondering why you know you're
happy to tell print journalists about it
but you're not happy to tell broadcast
journalists about it i mean on a related
topic
yesterday we heard in the papers that
boris johnson is worried about a second
wave
this morning in the papers more
anonymous briefing suggesting that the
scientists are
if you're worried about a second wave
why aren't you telling us why are we
getting all this
behind the scenes briefing going on
what's we're in the middle of a vinyl
pandemic
well i am i am worried about a second
wave i think you can see a
second wave starting to roll across
europe and we've got to do everything we
can
to prevent it from reaching these shores
and to tackle it
and you know the measures that the chief
medical officer will set out later are
part of that
but so too are the measures that we're
taking uh for instance to ensure that we
don't directly
uh bring cases back to this country
where there's a big spike in cases
for instance as we saw in spain we keep
those quarantine
those quarantine rules under review all
of the time
and we'll be we're taking action and we
will take action
if it is needed to keep this country
safe so absolutely on a on a second wave
it is something that i
i i worry about and i worry about it
because we can see it happening
you know around the rest of the world
outside of europe
there are clearly a very sharp increases
in the number of cases
in places like brazil mexico india and
other places
but but but but closer to home in europe
including in some of the countries that
we had exempted from quarantine because
their cases were so low
we're seeing that come up and we won't
hesitate to act
i apologize if there's a touch of
frustration edging into my tone because
to be honest with you i just like to
know things before other people
but another piece of briefing put to the
telegraph yesterday
you know ministers looking to reduce uh
the 14-day quarantine period
for people coming into the united
kingdom i mean is that true
well we're always looking to how we can
we can have the least possible burden of
the measures that we have to put into
place
so that is something on which uh we're
doing some work but we will only come
forward with a proposal
when it is when we are confident that it
is
it is safe to do so so again this is a
very much guided by the
clinical science um and the cmo will be
speaking on it later today
but the broader point is that
there is a serious concern about a
second wave that's clearly now
moving across europe and we need to take
action
and action to protect this country and
protect everybody in it
and if that means increasing the number
of
days that people who tested positive
have to self-isolate
then so be it because these measures are
necessary to keep people safe
here's one that i'm sure you can answer
is it the case as is also being reported
in some of the papers this morning that
they are number and the south west and
the south east of england is now above
one that we are seeing
exponential growth again
well it's uh we these public these
figures are published by the
statisticians and there'll be another
publication
tomorrow um and i'm not going to
prejudge again what the statisticians
say because it's important to do this
properly
but we have seen that the number of
cases which was coming down
uh pretty sharply that has flattened off
the number of people who have
uh positive cases um and
we follow these things very very closely
but i think you can see from what i'm
saying that
we have significant concerns about the
second wave that is coming across europe
and uh it's you know it's not just spain
you mentioned spain but there are other
countries too where the number of cases
is
rising and we're absolutely determined
to do everything
that we can to keep this country safe
and to make sure that we are protected
from it
i i wonder mr how concerned you are
about the story on the front of the mail
and actually picked up in
a number of places this morning that in
terms of access to gp
surgeries nine out of ten people these
days are having their consultation
over the phone via video call or so on i
mean
are you happy with that state of affairs
given how long it's been since you
said that the nhs should start getting
back to normal
i'm incredibly pleased with the increase
in
the number of people who are able to
access their gp
uh whether online or by the phone is one
of the big changes that we've seen
and we've seen it right across the board
and in the same way that
you know people are working from home
more
far more people are choosing to uh to
talk to their gp either
so is this the new normal then is this
the new normal in terms of accessing gps
gp services that we should expect just
as a matter of course
that we will be doing it not face to
face but in the main
all over video of course the
face-to-face appointment needs to be
there for people
who who need it and there's many many
medical procedures that you simply can't
do
online or over the phone um and um
but the increase in the number of people
who want to access their gp
by video call or on the phone and the
increase in the number of gps who
offer those services you know the number
offering video conferencing has gone
from
under 10 to almost 100 during this
crisis that is a good thing
now the figures specifically that you
mentioned in some of the newspapers i
don't recognize
again there's the statistics on this
coming out later this week
but but at the moment it's about 50 50
if you look at the latest
stats that is radically up from where it
was before the crisis
and this is one of the good things
that's happened it's also on the whole
very popular both amongst gps
and their teams in the practices and
amongst patients now of course some
people don't want to do that and they
want
to have a face-to-face gp appointment
and that will
always be available but for the vast
majority of people
who would prefer to be able to do it
that way the fact that it's now very
widely available is a very good thing
and i'll be saying more about this in my
speech later today
mr hancock whilst i have you i'm always
on the lookout for interesting job
opportunities one has
been put on the gov uk website yeah a
broadcaster coming in to handle
televised media briefings now you know a
scottish accent
always works well in circumstances which
are fairly combative
what is the point of this rule i mean
isn't it just another layer
between you know the people and the
politicians why are we i'd rather speak
to you
than some well richard medley if he's
and still in line for the job
well uh now um after this interview i
i'll put your name forward i
i uh you know i think you've got enough
on your
already hell secretary believe me
people love seeing you on there on their
screen so i'll take that up that's a
it's a matter for number 10. i'll take
it up with them healthcare lovely to see
you this morning thanks for being with
us